King Canute greets in friendship his
Archbishop's and his diocesan bishops
and Earl thorkil and all his Earl's and
all his people where the men over 1200
were killed or a 200 ecclesiastic and
lay in England and I inform you that I
will be a gracious Lord and a faithful
observer of gods rights and just secular
law I have borne in mind the letters and
messages which Archbishop leafing
brought me from Rome from the Pope that
I should everywhere exalt God's praise
and suppress wrong and establish full
security by that power which it has
pleased God to give me since I did not
spare my money as long as hostility was
threatening you I have now with God's
help put an end to it with my money
[Music]
then I was informed that greater danger
was approaching us than we liked at all
and then I went myself with the men who
accompanied me to Denmark from where the
greatest injury had come to you and with
God's help I have taken measures so that
never henceforth shall hostility reach
you from there as long as you support me
rightly and my life lasts now I thank
Almighty God for his help and mercy that
I have so settled the great dangers
which were approaching us that we need
fear no danger to us from there but we
may reckon on full help and deliverance
if we need it now
it is my will that we all thank Almighty
God humbly for the mercy which he has
shown for our help now I pray my
Archbishop's and all my diocese and
bishops that they all may be zealous
about God's to use each in the district
which is entrusted to him and also I
charge all my elder men that they may
help the bishops in furthering God's
rights and my royal dignity and the
benefit of the people
[Music]
if anyone ecclesiastic all a mundane or
Englishman is so presumptuous as to defy
God's law and my royal authority or the
secular law and he will not make amends
and desist according to the direction of
my bishops I then pray and also command
Earl for Coe
if he can to cause the evildoer to do
right and if he cannot then it is my
will that with the power of us both he
shall destroy him in the land or drive
him out of the land whether he be of
high or low rank
and also I charge all my Reeves on pain
of losing my friendship and all that
they possess and there are lives that
everywhere they maintain my people
justly and give just judgments with the
witness of the bishops and of the
diocese and practice such mercy therein
as seems just to the bishop of the
diocese and can be supported and if
anyone gives asylum to a thief or
interferes on his behalf
he is to be liable to the same penalty
to me as the thief unless he can clay
himself of liability to me with the full
process of exculpation and it is my will
that all the nation ecclesiastical and
lay shall steadfastly observe Edgar's
laws which all men have chosen and sworn
to at Oxford for all the bishops say
that the breaking of oaths and pledge is
to be very deeply atoned for with
God and also they teach us further that
we must with all our strength and all
our might earnestly seek love and honor
the eternal merciful God and shun all
evil doing namely the deeds of homicides
and murderers and perjuries and wizards
and sorcery seized and adulterers and
incestuous deeds and also we command in
the name of God Almighty and of all his
saints that no man is to be so
presumptuous as to take to wife a woman
consecrated to a life of chastity or a
nun and if anyone has done so he is to
be an outlaw before God and
excommunicated from all Christendom and
to forfeit to the king all the dione
unless he'd assists quickly and the
tones very deeply to God
and moreover we admonished that the
Sunday Festival is to be observed and
honored with all one's might from Sunday
noon until dawn on Monday and that no
one is to be so presumptuous as either
to practice any trade or to attend any
meeting on that holy day and all men
poor and rich are to go to their church
and make supplication for their sins and
to observe zealously every appointed
fast and honor readily those Saints
whose feasts the priests shall enjoin on
us so that all together through the
mercy of the eternal God and the
intercession of his Saints we can and
may come to the Bliss of the heavenly
kingdom and dwell with him who liveth
and reigneth ever without end our men
[Music]